عن سلاح روسيا قديم متجدد قد يكون وسيله
لروسيا في محاولتها صد الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد بحسب تقرير لصحيفه تيلغراف
البريطانيه الحديث هنا عن القنابل
الانزلاقيه او المجنحه التي نراها التي
بامكانها ان تعطي روسيا افضليه نسبيه في
المعارك المقبله فكيف ربما هذه الميزه
لروسيا القنابل تحلق على ارتفاعات منخفضه
نسبيا ما يبعدها عن خطر بعض الدفاعات
الجويه التي يتحكم فيها الرادار كما انها
تتمتع بقدره تدمير كبيره ايضا هذه القنابل
صغيره الحجم ارخص ايضا مقارنه بالصواريخ
الباليستيه انها قنابل موجهه وخفيفه الوزن
نسبيا وفي حدود الطن والنصف كما ذكرنا
السلاح ليس جديدا اعلن عنه الجيش الروسي
عام
1994 القنابل الانزلاقيه الروسيه مشاهدينا
هي مصممه ايضا بشكل يمنحها امكانيات
اختراق الاهداف ذات التحصين والحمايه
العاليه اما مدى هذه القناه في المتوسط
فيصل الى اربعين كيلو مترا بعد اطلاقها
عبر الطائرات المقاتله وفق خبراء اوكرانيا
بامكانها صدى الهجمات باستخدام وحدات
صواريخ سام او منظومه الا ان مواجهه
صواريخ غاليه الثمن صواريخ رخيصه ومعدله
قد يكون جزءا من الهدف الروسي لاستفاد
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات